en france le chef de l'état lance à
nouveau un appel à la solidarité
nationale l empêchera at il dit dans un
quartier modeste de nantes que le fort
soit toujours plus fort au détriment du
faible visite filmée et commenté par
renaud fessaguet et yves barbe
c'est de ce quartier est partie
l'insurrection des sans logis de nantes
après le terrible hiver 54 une zone de
taudis et de squats
quarante ans après françois mitterrand a
choisi la cité de l'abbé pierre
avec ces pavillons repeint financé par
la mairie pour rencontrer une population
souvent aux portes de l'exclusion un
symbole calculer et surtout une occasion
de souligner l'indispensable solidarité
seule la collectivité nationale ou des
collectivités locales
conscientes de leurs responsabilités ce
que vous faites ici monsieur le maire
mesdames et messieurs les conseillers
municipaux
seule cette solidarité en pèsera une
fort soit toujours plus fort au
détriment du faible du pot du démuni ou
de l'abandonner qui sera toujours le
plus faible et la loi du plus fort sous
nos latitudes s'appelle l'argent roi
françois mitterrand n'a pas prononcé le
mot mais on a profité pour dresser un
catalogue des priorités sociales à
l'intention du gouvernement aux
associations de quartier il a expliqué
qu'elle était l'âme de la démocratie
locale aux jeunes beurs il a répété
qu'il était pour le vote des immigrés à
tous
il a dit sa préoccupation de voir les
remboursements de la sécurité sociale
baisser toujours plus la france des
exclus avait sans doute besoin
d'entendre ces mots là non aussi qui n'a
pas vu deux présidents de la république
depuis 34 ans et qui compte aujourd'hui
20 % de chômeurs